[Music]
we're the California Highway Patrol
this job is crucial by without us out
there get hurt
California Highway Patrol think they
have some crooked cops you want you to
go on the inside go on the cover within
the department that's awesome we put you
with a rookie named Jon Baker
tell him my plan francis llewellyn
poncherello are the first two female
names John I like you here my maid my
husband he is really handsome you've had
23 surgeries and you can ride a
motorcycle I'll give you that
yes ma'am like a mother hmm what's up
I'm John poncherello
awesome man we're partners let's kick
this off with the real name Oh to your
homophobic or whatever that's cool no no
no no no no no you think I'm home Baker
Baker oh pretty badass you ain't all
suited up for battle but looking like
UPS drivers super cool go Brown this job
is my one shot it saved me my marriage
what are you wearing my uniform it's
like you're three beers too intimate
Alma tough motorcycle cop I got no
emotion what's your job find the dirty
cops check it you're FBI yep hey we need
to focus
are you kidding me right now I'm just
like powerless when it comes to yoga
pants you let's get you out of this
parking lot you have a visible erection
you think you can ride with that I don't
know you don't know who this department
is in on this we're like jay-z and
Beyonce we ride or die
I'm jay-z you screw up this case your
fight you've got a legitimate lead oh we
have a suspects head that's a victory
nasty I was just damn nasty I need to
get into some warm water my gonna care
you there I saved your life good and you
you were gonna bring it up
Grammy get it with your face plan might
know there's no contest that could have
swore I felt even your nose or your lips
no I'm I've been like a look a little
bit of contact
now repeat back what I just said
hold it no now that's the button of them
kill everyone try again
conk Oh mmm